and we'll begin this hour with breaking
news out of the United States and the
Pentagon has confirmed that it plans to
send controversial cluster Munitions to
Ukraine let's go straight to our U.S
correspondent Mark stone for the very
latest on this uh Mark it's good to have
you with us so it was it was trailed
from earlier today that these cluster
bombs could be sent to Ukraine but now
that confirmation has come in what are
we expecting the Americans to send to
the ukrainians
yeah on the face of it this is highly
controversial cluster Munitions are a
very very controversial form of
artillery they are banned by 123
countries around the world a 2008
convention uh bans their use or their
transfer to other countries almost all
NATO countries are signatory uh to this
convention with the exception of a
couple including the United States
um these weapons have been used by
Russia on the battlefield in Ukraine
they have also been used by Ukraine
against Russia Ukraine using their own
existing supplies of cluster Munitions
but now controversially the United
States has announced that it will supply
its own dormant stockpile of cluster
Munitions up to Ukraine to allow them to
use them on the battlefield now why is
this controversial well because
um statistics suggest that 97 of victims
of cluster Munitions that have been used
in past Wars are civilians because of
the nature of a cluster munition it is
one bomb which is dropped or fired from
the ground at a battlefield and when it
when it impacts or just before impact it
um it throws out many many small
bomblets over a wide area many of those
or a proportion of those do not explode
and other let them left providing a
legacy of problems down the line and
civilians many of them children in
places like Syria and other places uh
are the um the victims of this Legacy
weapon now the Americans are arguing uh
that the time has come where they have
no choice really but to supply Ukraine
with this weapon they are saying that
they're not supplying it just because
the Russians are using it they are
supplying a cluster weapon which is more
sophisticated than the Russian one the
Americans arguing that the the risk to
civilians is lower because fewer of the
bomblets uh will will uh will will not
explode on impact in other words most of
them will would explode at the time and
so there is less of a legacy problem
they also admitting the Americans are
admitting that there is a massive supply
chain shortage the ukrainians are
running out of existing Weaponry
um uh Weaponry in the form of existing
more conventional artillery and so a
supply bridge is needed and to fill that
Gap because the Americans haven't got
enough conventional artillery to be able
to supply to the ukrainians they are
deciding announcing today as you can see
here that they will be supplying these
cluster Munitions up to the ukrainians
look I think on the face of it Kamali
what this what this tells us is that
Ukraine is not winning this fight at the
moment the long-awaited spring offensive
may as well be called the summer
offensive now even the Autumn offensive
because it simply hasn't materialized uh
combine that with a shortage of of
artillery and the Americans are now
doing what many within the United States
Administration did not want to do and
supplying this very very controversial
weapon to Ukraine it is that the caveat
the Americans are saying is that Ukraine
will be using it on its own soil the
onus is therefore on Ukraine to clear up
the mess after presumably hopefully the
Americans would say it's one and uh the
Americans will say they will help the
ukrainians to to clear up any any mess
in terms of mine clearance and munition
clearance down the line but yeah this is
this is a big highly controversial
decision
it certainly is a mark and it comes as
part of a huge new military package
that's going to the Ukraine some 800
million dollars worth of military aid
it's going to include armored vehicles
as well including the Bradley and the
striker
um how how has this decision been
received uh by politicians in the United
States you said there were some
reticence to do it but I guess there's
all that also comes up against the idea
that America the US does not want to
keep having to supply money and arms to
Ukraine and want to try and get some
kind of decisive breakthrough as part of
this offensive
yeah actually I do I do think there is
an attempt and I've heard this a few
times recently uh to
um the phrase being used is to Future
proof uh the conflict I mean there was
no guarantee uh that there will be uh
never-ending support for Ukraine um
American politics is in flux as an
election next year there is the prospect
of uh a change of government here which
may mean less support for Ukraine so
there's an attempt now to front load uh
Ukraine with the Weaponry it needs so
that if if needed it can fight its own
war and it's got the Weaponry front
loaded future-proofed uh if if there is
any sort of change in policy uh back
here in terms of American political
reaction not much at the moment there
has been unease even within the state
department as recently as a week ago
about whether or not to supply these
weapons um uh to Ukraine uh decision has
now been made as is being announced that
that they will supply it I think there
is some unease among European allies I
mean after all most countries Britain
included are signatories to this
agreement not to use or Supply to others
immune cluster Munitions I mean it
wasn't all that long ago that we were
doing reports about the Russians using
custom Munitions in places like Syria
and the controversies surrounding that
the difference the Americans would argue
is that the ukrainians are not going to
be using these Munitions on civilian
populations they will be using it on
battlefields in the east of their own
country and and it will and on in a
military sense have a decisive impact
because of the the nature of these
weapons they can wipe out large areas of
um of heavily dug in Russian soldiers I
think we've got a um a a Quick Clip here
from Jake Sullivan the National Security
advisor for President Biden preempting
the announcement that we're now hearing
from the Pentagon and defending what is
a controversial decision
we have provided Ukraine with a historic
amount of unitary artillery rounds and
we are ramping up domestic production of
these rounds we've already seen
substantial increases in production but
this process will continue to take time
and it will be critical to provide
Ukraine with a bridge of supplies while
our domestic production is ramped up we
will not leave Ukraine defenseless at
any point in this conflict period
second Russia has been using cluster
Munitions since the start of this war to
attack Ukraine
Russia has been using cluster Munitions
with high dud or failure rates of
between 30 and 40 percent
in this environment Ukraine has been
requesting cluster Munitions in order to
defend its own Sovereign territory the
cluster Munitions that we would provide
have dud rates far below what Russia is
doing is is providing not higher than
2.5 percent
and
the Americans are accepting that there
is a legacy risk to civilians from this
decision but their argument is that the
risk to civilians of not supplying this
weapon is greater because the risk to
civilians from Russia occupying and
attacking Ukrainian territory is greater
than the risk of providing these cluster
Munitions nevertheless as the dust
settles on this decision it will be seen
as highly controversial and some will
argue that America will lose the moral
High Ground in this war by providing
such a controversial weapon